ok so it's 10 o'clock at night and me
and Amanda have suddenly had a
spontaneous idea that we want to drive
to Oxford because we've got a serviced
accommodation property that it's
supposed to be being finished today the
bill does all the maintenance people
have said that today it will be finished
so we're gonna drive down we might catch
them there and let's see how the Provost
is doing and hopefully you'll be
finished if it is we might even sleep
there how's it going man awesome bro
hey guys is it a nice place is it so
this is a Ryan and Adam what is it that
you guys do assemble and dress looks
like you're doing an awesome job man
nice central location with like that
drive it up dark now it's got to be
about midnight these are really handy
for me to grab on to my bad leg it's
quite quirky ok there's another story
which I didn't know about it's my first
time here and it actually looks like we
could sleep here tonight if you want are
you sleeping over here tonight guys yeah
so when did you start furniture in this
place I rarely listen so the night small
work
it feels very spacious Mary Bryan do you
reckon that it's gonna rent out whether
serviced accommodation would you stay
here for the night yeah well you kind of
ask nice
you gotta keep safe outside yet is it
quite nice
not much of a year at the moment cuz
it's so dark but so this looks like the
top floor I think this is probably gonna
be where I sleep tonight
what you think don't I love it
it's beautiful I love the kitchen as
well especially downstairs would you be
happy if you booked tonight here
[Music]
nice one good morning guys so it's her
morning time we just had a good sleep
and yeah really looking nice the guys
are finishing furnishing it now and it
really is so where are we exactly well
we're in a place called Woodstock which
is not that close talks percent it's
about 20 minutes away from Oxford Centre
so we were a little unsure about whether
this place would work for serviced
accommodation however have to speak to a
vivo and did some market research in the
area we found that the hotels here are
always fully booked Aviva our management
company they said it would work well so
we're gonna give it a try this is the
house and you can actually see Blenheim
Palace right here which is a very famous
and beautiful building and there are a
lot of shops and stuff around so it's a
very desirable area so that one of the
figures well we're gonna be paying for
the for the whole house three bedrooms
lovely Connick cottagey property will be
paying 1,300 pounds per month to the
landlord but the the income that we're
going to receive from this I mean it's
looking like it's gonna be about 200
pounds per night we'll be able to rent
it out and that's not pervert that's
just we're gonna rent the whole house
out just as like a family cottage I
think so too new pound per night we've
worked on a basis after Payne cleaners
paintball the booking fees and also take
into account voids but we should be
making around about two thousand pounds
per book on this property we're leasing
the furniture but we have had to pay a
few thousand pounds as a like you know a
set of faith so the return on investment
is just
after Silvie bled through the roof
normally we do invest closest the city
center so if it works it's just going to
be incredible so I'll keep you posted
how it goes and right now I'm going to
be able to miss the shopping center to
do a bit of shopping and get some
breakfast what did you what's your
problem is too many sofas and Nando
suggestion was to take instead she's not
really gonna have fun but at night I
strike tell Amanda oh he got there in
the end
just about so Amanda it's now morning
time we're gonna take a walk / go
shopping what do you think man how much
does this if I YouTube followers would
like to stay here would they be allowed
it'd be allowed to stay if you want to
come and check it out and see what it's
like see how the keysight system works
and everything then we'll maybe leave a
booking link below
that's my sales pitch for this video
that's it just arrived in vista shopping
center and who's that I mean Leslie's
husband Remy
good to meet you bro and the lady
yourself who is Leslie I mean one of the
Chancellor's she has does it happen to
me in Oxford Leslie's killing it on
service combination as well and you want
to come and stay in my house yes and I
should come stay in your house yes
Bilson and Mandy you may get a discount
on your new back she said what kind of
discounts to do this is we only do stuff
discount 20% gee whiz she says that will
do fine and then they scan it right
through so below market value handbag
and a lot of fun so peace out guys see
you next time
[Music]